it's the perfect weather to celebrate
mardi gras let's check back in with
rocky she is live at vegas test kitchen
in downtown where they are having the
ultimate fat tuesday pizza party hey
rocky
hey guys okay so of course on mardi gras
traditionally you got to throw some
beads yeah we won't talk about you know
what you got to do for beads okay but
we're going to throw your beads right
now so officially mardi gras go
hey
here we go another part what time does
the party start here at vegas tesco
cheating is at 4 30 and then we have one
more at 6 30.
right so everyone has pre-purchased
tickets
that good luck there's a bumble bee
hanging out oh god
so um
there are a few extra seats so we're
gonna do a little a la carte menu for a
few people we prepped a little bit extra
so if you show up at the door
feel free to walk in you might get lucky
that is a special very exclusive
invitation okay because reservations are
full everyone is coming here for mardi
gras to party and celebrate right now
we're in their alley they're outdoor
seating and it's beautiful outside as we
mentioned and what's on the menu besides
the pizza that we're going to get to
shrimp boys dirty rice and sausage we
have gumbo the gumbo is seafood and
chicken and then we also have a pie from
popping pies which we mentioned before
but like let's look at this pizza oh my
gosh okay so let's talk about pizza now
because we're having a pizza party for
mardi gras that is actually very unique
and i love that concept
but it is mardi gras themed correct
correct okay who wants to tell me about
the pizza it's a mufletta style pizza so
we have a house made jar naira that our
team came up with has provolone gabagool
also known as
coppa we get some soprasada
and some genoa salami on there oh my
gosh
well we're talking about a bunch of meat
on this pizza because for fat tuesday
this is when you indulge in fatty foods
you indulge in junk food you indulge in
meat and then you let it all go tomorrow
fresh wednesday or or not we know
whatever you prefer whatever you prefer
but tell us about uconn what you guys
and what you guys are bringing to the
table tonight we're yukon pizza and
we're at 125 year old heirloom sourdough
starter family so this is an old
sourdough crust you're trying with chef
came with the pizza last year and we're
doing another one this year he's
actually going to finish it off for us
right now oh yeah ooh can i do the
honors can i do the honors
or some zap chips okay okay so about
some uh garlic oil on the crust right
here oh my gosh it smells so good out
here y'all i'm gonna get crazy a little
bit of everything bagel seasoning on the
side like that
with some giardiniera
on the top like that
wow and this is interesting because you
guys actually put the pizza in the oven
just as a cheese pizza and then
afterwards is when you actually put the
toppings on we did the whole thing
besides the garnishes in the oven so do
you want to put in the final ones the
zap chips just get it oh this is i just
what's the technique oh salt bake i was
about to put the whole container on
there you go let's get in there boom
it is officially mardi gras the party
has started i and then i want the i'm
you guys i am about to indulge heavily
here in vegas test kitchen i will send
it back to you can we get a knife or
something
she's ready having the best assignment
of the week i'm telling you thank you so
much rocky that all looks so good